est-ce que c'est possible que vous me le
gardiez
oh non et bien sachez que Christophe
Dechavanne sera avec son mari sur notre
plateau pour la Saint-Valentin
Christophe Beaugrand j'ai dit de
Chavanne
près de 20% des jeunes interrogés Jérôme
Jaffray estime que la science apporte à
l'homme plus de mal que de bien plus
d'un quart des 11 24 ans remettent en
question la théorie de l'évolution est
considère que nous ne descendons pas du
singe comme la bien établie pourtant
Charles Darwin mais que nous aurions été
créés par une force spirituelle qu'on
peut appeler Dieu par exemple et puis de
la même façon un jeune sursis pense que
la terre est plate on les appelle les
platistes et quasiment un sur trois chez
les tiktokers ça monte à 29%. 41% des
jeunes sur TikTok croient en l'idée que
plus un influenceur a d'abonnés plus
c'est une source fiable d'information
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
ça m'inspire si vous voulez que tout
cela est très inquiétant bien évidemment
je vois pas ce qu'il y a de l'intérêt a
toujours être sur les réseaux sociaux ça
sert à rien ça n'apporte rien à notre
vie que des soucis en fait donc faut
vivre la vie qu'on allait pour regarder
autour de soi pas sur son téléphone faut
passer à autre chose comme tous les
soirs dans ce village depuis 5 mois
à 19h précises une sirène retentit
elle indique que tous les habitants
doivent déconnecter leurs appareils
numériques c'est une obligation
et là c'est mes petits chouchous c'est
deux petits filtres bon celui-ci on a la
possibilité de faire la bouche en
maquillée ou non grâce à la déconnexion
numérique notre famille a changé
désormais nous avons 1h30 pour interagir
les uns avec les autres plutôt que de
regarder nos portables ou la télé
ce qui ne respecte pas cette règle
risque jusqu'à 12 euros d'amende on est
en train de détruire totalement
totalement nos enfants parce que c'est
absolument aberrant qu'un enfant soit ne
comprennent pas très tôt et très vite ce
qu'est ce qu'est l'autorité le respect
de l'autre voilà et ça je vais vous dire
que c'est principe là autorité respect
et et j'irai adhésion si on ne fait pas
ça à un enfant vous en faites
potentiellement des délinquants les gens
des des enfants à problèmes des mauvais
élèves à l'école dans les salles de
classe les résultats se sont vite fait
sentir
regardez c'est l'écriture du même élève
avant et après vous pouvez voir la
différence avant il ne travaillait pas
et trouver toujours de fausses excuses
mais maintenant ils étudient ils font
leur devoirs
c'est ça la vraie question mais
réellement la supprimer
de cette société c'est que les gens
c'est difficile d'avoir accès à la
formation parce qu'en fait la
surinformation fait que c'est difficile
d'avoir accès à l'information c'est
difficile de la trier c'est difficile de
savoir ce qui est vrai ce qui est pas
vrai c'est on est on est on est enseveli
sur l'information donc les gens ce qui
si vous n'avez pas un œil un peu pointu
ce n'est pas un peu journaliste si vous
n'avez pas une si vous n'avez pas aussi
grandi par exemple avec des parents qui
vous ont appris à lire moi par exemple
je suis par exemple dans une famille on
disait forcément le journal je dis juste
que est-ce que l'école c'est fait pour
gommer les inégalités la vie il y a
beaucoup d'inégalités dans la société il
y a beaucoup d'inégalité l'école ça fait
partie de la société donc si tu es pas
du tout alors si je vous demande qui a
construit les pyramides d'Égypte vous me
répondez ben oui et sauf que 19% des
sondés répondent des extraterrestres ils
sont aussi nombreux d'ailleurs 20% à
penser que les Américains ne sont jamais
allés sur la lune près d'un sur deux
chez les plus religieux ne dit-on pas
d'ailleurs que les influenceurs
d'influence que les influençables
les influenceurs ils vivent à Dubaï et
compagnie parce qu'on est toujours en
train de les aduler ces gens-là et en
plus ils en ont rien à faire de nous ce
qu'il voit c'est ce qui se met dans la
poche et ils vivent à Dubaï donc je vois
pas l'intérêt toujours garder ils sont
pas intéressants en plus ça fait combien
de temps d'abord avant tout ça combien
de temps
parce que là je vais t'aimer 10 ans de
carrière
donc moi j'aurais dix ans déjà quand
même on vous regardez la télévision bon
regardez votre journal mais on n'allait
pas forcément dans la presse donc tout
ce que vous disiez pour nous c'était
vrai et je dis pas que c'était pas vrai
[Rires]
ce que je veux dire pour moi la première
philosophie c'est déjà de se dire que
l'homme n'est pas au centre du monde
nous sommes pas dans une pensée
entreprises c'est que l'homme fait
l'unité avec les végétaux les minéraux
etc si votre cœur s'emballe à la vue de
votre chérie
vous faites une crise de bradycardie ou
de tachycardie
tachycardie oui bien sûr Brad Pitt a
beau essayer de se cacher à 59 ans la
simple vue de son visage provoque chez
les spectateurs un petit rire
caractéristiques
ok
Brad pittro
la bradycardie ça existe on aurait
plusieurs ça c'est une vanne par rapport
à Brad Pitt bah Brad Pitt
je suis enrhumé vous avez vu que j'ai eu
l'élégance de ne pas poser la question à
Madame Macron de lui demander qui était
le plus sexy des quatre qui a regardé
alors nous on dit un cinquième hein
le président bien sûr vous parlez d'un
homme qui vous plaît beaucoup qui est
très beau il fait de la politique qui
s'appelle Raphaël Luxman c'est ça mais
vous en parlez d'une manière très
comment dirais physique mais physique
montrez-moi ça non vous vous massez pas
sur insta non moi je le fais sur les
photos de Rafale Glucksman alors
peut-être vous connaissez pas en
Belgique c'est notre Georges Louis
boucher mais de gauche et c'est bien
parce que je me plains
elle me dit il est mieux que Christian
voilà
[Applaudissements]
remporte ce titre
9ème couronnement pour la candidate
américaine la déception en revanche pour
Floriane Bascou première dauphine l'an
dernier qui représentait notre pays en
l'absence de Miss France indisponible
pour la compétition elle n'a
malheureusement pas été retenu dans le
Top 16
si tu m'entends je fais passer un
message
[Applaudissements]
que je veux dans le podcast ou tous les
deux ne pas avoir peur vous voulez une
canne en fait c'est ça vous êtes bien
j'aime les gens intelligents